Okay,
let us start,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to pursue the issue of musical form today.
It's an important thing to talk about because it allows us to follow a
particular piece of music and we'll be using this metaphor of a musical journey
and wanting to know where we are in music throughout today.
Today form is particularly important in all types of music,
popular music as well as classical music.
And we have this complex of material coming at us,
the sonic material,
and we try to make sense of it and we say that it has a particular form and we
say it could have a particular structure even.
So we tend to use metaphors having to do with architecture and things such as
this.
Uh,
what we are really doing here is taking all of this sonic information that's
coming into our brain and getting sorted and makes us want to dance around or
clap or be sad or happy and make sense of it in terms of a few rather simple
patterns.
And musicians like to have forms because oftentimes it sort of tells them what
they ought to do next.
And we're here,
I'm here.
But what,
what ought to happen next?
Well,
if you've got a,
uh,
a tried and true musical form that other musicians have used over the years,
you might be inclined to use it too because you're no,
you know,
your listener will be able to follow you.
Now the other day I ask,
uh,
early on in the course about the form in popular music,
and I threw this out not really knowing what the answer would be.
What's the most common form that one encounters when dealing with pop songs?
And for the most part,
there was silence across the room,
but one student,
uh,
of I've tracked him down,
Fredrick Evans gave a very good answer of really have a better answer than I
could have given.
So clearly Frederick knew something about this idea of what he,
I think referred to as verse and chorus structure.
I might call it strokey and refrain,
but it's the same thing whether you have it in the lead of Franz Schubert or in
a piece that I know nothing about.
And Frederick is going to show us,
introduce us to a piece that I know nothing about.
I sent him an email last night saying,
Frederick,
you gave a really good answer.
Why don't you pick a piece,
come up and demonstrate this.
So this is Frederick Evans.
We're going to,
excuse me.
Yeah,
Fredric [inaudible].
He's going to come up here.
I'm told we have to give him a microphone.
And he is,
he is going to uh,
introduces to this particular p piece.
Now you probably all know what this piece is.
How many of you have heard the piece?
We were just listening to?
Everybody knows it.
Who's the one person in the room?
It's never heard this piece before.
It has no clue what's happening.
Wa Okay,
so Frederick,
tell me about this piece please.
Really like the archetype
of a lot of popular sons.
It's half of the half of the course are so inspiring.
So then there's first chorus,
first chorus,
and then when I call the bridge,
which is like an emotional climax.
And then the last one is a really powerful course where they just bring it home.
Okay.
So it's this idea of changing tax than coming back to familiar texts and
familiar music and changing,
going back to the unf familiar new tax and then coming back to the familiar in
terms of the chorus.
Is that a fair shake?
Yes sir.
Okay.
Uh,
so,
uh,
shall we play,
what are we going to hear first?
I,
so first you'll hear from seconds 24 to 40.
This is an example of the verse where they have the beginning of the plan and
then you have the chorus and second slower than about 56.
And that's where you're getting a repeating idea,
which is like what the piece is based on.
And then last but not least,
you have the emotional buildup where the background and the chord progression
changes a little more solidly.
And then there's the last quarter just brings it home.
Okay,
great.
Let's listen to the,
yeah,
probably gone
notice.
Hey Baby.
Okay.
That was good.
Yeah.
So that was the first,
first.
And that's where they really get you into what you're talking about.
Okay.
What really interests me is what they're using is a baroque ostinato lament
based,
but that's okay.
That's we'll get,
we'll get onto that in another week or so.
So that's okay.
Now we're go to the bridge Frederick.
Yes.
[inaudible] is where they really,
some of the body emotions and they really just want to tell you what they're
building towards
game.
We're back court.
Okay,
that's wonderful.
Thank you Fredrik.
That's exactly what I wanted.
Okay.
How many want Craig to continue teaching this course and how many want
Frederick,
let's hear it for Craig.
Let's hear it for Fredric [inaudible].
Okay.
But that's a good way of getting introduced to the idea of musical form.
Uh,
let's about form.
Now in classical music,
the forms are a little more difficult in classical music because the music is
more complex.
And before we launch into a discussion of,
of these musical forms,
I want to talk about the distinction between genre in music and form in music.
So we're going to go over to the board over here and you can see that I've
listed the standard classical genres.
What do we mean by genre in music?
Wealth simply musical type.
So we've got this type called a symphony in this type of music called a string
quartet and concerto.
So on.
We could add other types,
ballet opera things such as that.
In the pop realm we've got genres too.
We've got a,
uh,
classical new Orleans jazz would be a genre blues with G,
B,
uh,
a genre of grunge rock would be another sort of genre.
It's a genre,
presupposes a particular performing force,
a particular links of pieces and even dress and mode of behavior of the
auditors.
The listeners,
uh,
if we are going to listen to the genre of a symphony,
we would dress up one particular way,
go to Woolsey Hall and expect to be there from eight o'clock till 10 o'clock.
Uh,
if you were going to hear the rolling stones play at toads where they do play,
uh,
occasionally,
obviously one would not come at eight o'clock when we'd come later,
one would dress in a particular sort of way and one would behave presumably,
um,
in a,
in a different sort of way.
So that's what we mean by genre,
kind of tight general type of music.
Now today we'll start to talk about form in music.
And what I need to say here is that each of these genres is made up of a,
of movements and each of the movements is informed by a particular form.
So with the symphony we have four movements.
They're fast,
slow than either minuet or a sketch show and a final fast movement.
And each of these movements can be in one of a number of different forms and
we'll talk about what they are and just,
just a moment.
So,
uh,
when we come to the string quartet,
same sort of thing,
fast,
slow minuet,
sketchup fast.
Any one of those can be in a particular form concerto generally,
as mentioned before,
has just three movements and Sanada a piano sonata,
something played on a piano or a Violin Sonata with violin and piano
accompaniment,
they generally have just three movements.
Fast,
slow fash okay,
let's talk about our forms.
Now.
In classical music,
things go by very quickly and it's difficult to kind of get a handle on it.
And we generally in life don't like to be lost.
We'd like to know where we are,
we like to know what is happening and this is what form allows us to do so that
if we're hearing a piece of music and all this stuff is coming at us,
we want to make sense of it.
By knowing approximately where we are,
it's still towards the beginning.
Am I in the middle of this thing?
Am I getting anywhere near the end of it?
How should I,
how should I respond at this particular point?
Well,
if we have in mind what I've identified here and we will be referring to as our
six formal types,
and we can think of these as templates that when we're hearing a piece of music,
we make an educated decision about which formal type is in play and then we drop
down the model of this formal type or the template of this formal type.
And we sort of filter our listening experience through this template or through
this model.
So here are our six models,
ternary form,
Sonata,
allegro form,
theme and variations,
Rondo,
fugue and Ostinato.
And they developed at various times in the history of music theme and variations
is very old.
Sonata Allegro is a lot more recent now of these,
the ones that we'll be working with day are ternary form and Sonata Allegro form
a and Sonata Allegro is the hardest,
the most complex,
the most difficult of all of these forms.
It's so called because it usually shows up in the first movement of a Sonata
Concerto string,
Quartet symphony.
So,
and the first moments are fast.
So that's why we have a lay grow out there and it,
most is,
most is associated with this idea of the Sonata.
Um,
it didn't necessarily originate,
they're originated there and in the symphony,
uh,
but for historical reasons we call this Sonata because of its association with
the Sonata.
And the fast that it goes in the fact that it goes fast.
Sonata Allegro form,
so that in a symphony,
usually your very first movement will be in Sonata Allegro form your slow
movement.
Well that could be in theme and variations.
It could be in Rondo,
could be internal reform,
your minuet and scared.
So it was almost always internal reform.
And your last fast movement could be in Sonata Allegro form.
You could also be in theme and variations could be in Rondo,
could be infused.
Sometimes it's even in Austin auto form.
So you can see that these forms can show up,
uh,
and sort of control,
regulate what happens inside of each of these movements.
Okay.
Are there questions about that?
Does that seem straightforward enough?
We have big,
big picture of jewelry here,
movements within genre and then forms informing each of the movements.
Yes.
No,
uh,
um,
I said it's possible that it is,
could be used for the second movement.
I turn reform is one of the forms that could be used with the SEC,
the slow second movement.
Uh,
we could also have theme and variations.
We're going to hear one of those later in our course.
Uh,
it could also be a sort of slow Rondo,
um,
is so it's just one of,
of really three possibilities there.
But thanks for that question.
Anything else?
Okay.
If not,
let's talk then about ternary form because ternary form has much in common with
what we experience in Sonata Allegro form.
Let me take a very straight forward example of Turner reform.
Uh,
it's from Beethoven's for Elise,
that piece,
that piano piece,
the Beethoven wrote for one of his para Moore's at one time or another.
Whoops,
I knew this would happen.
I'm going to tell you a story about this.
My cell phone broke the other day,
go away.
so I had to buy a new one that was really happy about that.
I hate that he did to lose my old Mozart,
a theme.
But,
um,
I then had to find a new Mozart theme.
And nowadays my selections are more limited.
So when you go on to these things,
and in truth,
I actually had my youngest son do this because I'm hopelessly in competent with
this kind of thing.
You go onto these things and now they only have one option,
one option for classical music,
one option for it,
but it's called Mozart.
So good choice.
Mozart has become the icon of classical music.
And I think it it,
it's the individual that should be the icon for classical music.
All classical music now has been reduced down to just Mozart.
Okay.
I had no idea what that was about,
but uhW,
who's calling?
All right.
Um,
so we have this piece,
internal reform by Beethoven and turn reform is conveys to,
is simply the idea of presentation,
diversion,
re presentation or statement,
digression,
restatement,
anything like this.
We like to diagram these in terms of alphabetical letters.
You can think of just a be a,
Oh,
all right.
I'm going to pause here.
We started out right
here.
We are in this key major or minor.
What do you think,
Mike?
All right,
so we were coming to the end of this a section here.
The age section is very short.
Okay.
But then
we made your minor major.
Wow.
So what happened there?
What do we call this?
It's a very quick modulation.
Very quick modulation.
We've changed keys and I'm going to digress here just for a moment to talk about
this,
which is this concept of relative major and minor.
You may have noticed in music,
and it's discussed briefly in the textbook,
that there are payers of keys,
pairs of keys that have something in common.
The members of the payers have the same key signature.
We could take any key signature,
three flats or or two sharps,
whatever.
But there's going to be one major key with three flats and one minor key with
three flats.
Uh,
and I think we have up on the board here an example of just that.
So you can see written in here the three flats,
and this is a minor scale with three flats.
Now we could also have three flats over here,
but we encounter three flats when we'd have the major scale.
This happens to work out so that it's pitched on.
See if we come up three half steps in the keyboard,
we come up to e flat.
So the relative major,
the major key,
and this pair is always three half steps.
One,
two,
three,
half steps up above,
it's paired minor.
Here's another one down at the bottom.
Happens to have one sharp in it.
We have the key of g major here with one sharp,
but if we come down three half steps we get it's relative minor down here.
And the reason I mentioned this is not because we actually hear this very much,
I'm not sure that I hear modulations to relative major because I don't have
absolute pitch and I'm not tracking keys.
When I listened to pieces,
my guess is you're not either.
So for the average listener we may not hear that the actual pitch relationship,
but we may hear that we've had a modulation and you can kind of make an educated
guess that about 50% of the time if it's going minor to major,
it's coming in this relative arrangement or major down to minor.
It's going in this relative arrangement.
So this happens,
this happens a lot.
So here we are in the mid section of our ternary form a be a here's the a B
party
and then back to the minor.
Hmm.
Well that's just the opening section of this piece.
It goes on to do other things,
but it is a very succinct example of Turner for and turn reform is a useful way
of introducing a larger concept which is Sonata Allegro form.
So let me flip the board here
and here we go.
On to this rather complex diagram.
As I say,
it's the most complex one of all the six forms that we'll be working with.
It consists of three essential parts,
exposition development and recapitulation.
So you could think of your coming out of ternary form.
You've got an a here,
you've got to be idea here and then you've got an a return back here.
But this is a lot more complicated.
The things,
lots of things going on.
And I should say also in terms of fairness in advertising that this is a model.
This is also something of an abstraction or an ideal,
not every piece written in Sonata Allegro form conforms to this diagram in all
particulars.
You know,
composers wouldn't want to do that.
They'd have to assert their independence or originality in one way or another.
But it's a useful sort of model.
It tells us what the norm is,
what we can generally expect.
So we've got these three sort of CNA quad known here,
and then we've got two optional,
uh,
parts of this that we'll talk about as we proceed.
So this is the layout then for Sonata,
Allegro form,
exposition development,
recapitulation.
So we start out with the first theme in the tonic key.
Of course,
uh,
it might even have subsets to it so that we can have one a and one B and one c
up here.
I won't put them up there,
but it can happen.
Then we have a transition in which we have a change of key moving to the
dominant key transitions tend to be rather unsettled.
It gives you the sense of moving somewhere,
going somewhere.
That's why it's called a transition.
Uh,
it could also musicians like quickly like to call it a bridge.
It's sort of leading you somewhere else.
It may be it in that way.
It is similar to the type of bridge that Frederick was talking about earlier.
So we have a transition or bridge.
It takes us to the second theme in now in the dominant key.
If,
however,
our symphony happened to begin in a minor key,
then the second theme,
we'd come in,
in the relative major.
So if we had a c minor as Beethoven does in his Fifth Symphony,
so there we are there and c minor,
but the second theme
is in the relative major of e flat.
Both have three flats in it.
So if you happen to start in and composers traditionally modulate not to the
dominant but to the relative major which is up on the third degree of the scale,
that's why there's a big three there.
So then the second theme comes in,
it's usually contrasting,
lyrical,
sweeter.
You heard the difference there.
Um,
more song like in the Beethoven,
not so much of that musical punch in the nose as I like to refer to it,
but,
uh,
um,
more,
uh,
relaxed,
sort of second theme and there's oftentimes some filler or what we might call an
interest to see.
And we come to a closing theme that's abbreviated up here.
Just the t closing theme of the exposition closes the exposition closing themes
tend to be rather simple and which they rock back and forth between dominant and
tonic so that you can end on the tonic and that gives you a sense of conclusion
of the exposition.
Now what happens,
will you see these dots up on the board?
Anybody know what these dots mean?
I think we actually,
we talk about this.
If you read ahead in the textbook,
uh,
somebody tell me what the dots mean.
Um,
Jerry.
Okay,
repeat.
so that's what Dotson music.
We have these double bars and dots.
That means repeat,
so we got to repeat the whole exposition.
It didn't like it.
First Time we get a second pass at it in the repeat.
Then we'd go on to the development and as the term development suggest,
we're going to develop the theme here.
But it is oftentimes more than that.
It could be something other than just the development and the expansion.
It could actually be a contraction.
Beethoven likes to strip away things and sort of play with a particular subsets
of themes or play with parts of motives.
Generally speaking,
your development is characterized by tonal instability,
moves around a lot.
You can't tell what key you're in tonal in stability,
and it also tends to be in terms of texture,
the most polyphonic of any section in the piece.
There's a lot of counterpoint usually to be found in the development section.
Then towards the end of the development section,
we want to get back here to the return and we want to get back to our first
theme and our tonic key.
So composers oftentimes will sit on one chord.
What they will sit on will happen to be the dominant,
so I could put that up here.
We could put a five up here because we want a long period of dominant
preparation.
Bob [inaudible]
bom is where we're going back over here,
but we're going to set this up with preparation in terms of the dominant that
wants to push us into the tunnel.
So there we are back in the tonic now and all the first themes come back as they
did before.
We also have a bridge,
but this time it does not modulate.
It stays in the tonic key.
We don't want it to modulate because we've got to finish in the tonic here.
So I was thinking just a moment ago,
it's kind of the bridge to nowhere.
It really is a bridge to nowhere.
You stay right back where you are.
You stay in that tonic key and the second theme material comes in,
you're closing theme comes in and you could end the composition here.
Sometimes Mozart,
as we will see in our course,
we'll end a piece right at this point.
Uh,
the end right there.
but more often than not,
composers,
we'll throw on a coat off.
What's a coated do?
Well,
it really,
uh,
says to the listener that hey,
the pieces sort of at an end here,
code is generally are very static harmonically.
There's not a lot of movement.
It's an eye I keep,
maybe I should have got to come up with a different metaphor here.
The idea of throwing an anchor over,
slowing the whole thing down,
simplifying it to say we're at the end.
So you get a lot of the
bump,
bom,
Bom,
bom
kind of things in a Coda just to,
to tell the listener,
it's time to think about clapping.
At this point we're reaching for your coat.
And the other optional Coda,
what's,
I'd come from,
uh,
the Latin,
Kauders cow.
Dot.
Aghast Cada Italian Coda,
um,
means tail.
And these can be like all tails,
longs or shorts.
Mozart happened to like short code is a Beethoven liked Wonger COTAs.
And the other optional component here is the introduction.
My guess is Jacob,
what would you guess how many,
what portion of classical symphonies,
you're an orchestral player,
but portion of classical symphonies would begin with an introduction.
Would you say
most of them?
Well,
we'll,
we'll consider that.
Let's,
let's go for 50% at the,
at the moment we'll consider a a 50% at the moment.
Um,
so we'll see.
We'll sit,
now let's jump into
a classical composition.
The begins with a movement and snot allegro form.
We're going to close.
We're going to open here with Mozart's,
I declined to knock music a little night music.
This is sort of serenade stuff that he wrote,
uh,
for um,
for uh,
Vienna sort of night music,
evening music.
Let's listen to a little of it.
Um,
Linda,
just start out here.
We're going to start with the first theme idea and before she does,
let me play this.
What about that conjunct or disjunct melody
this junk.
Yeah,
there's a lot of jumping around here kind of thing.
Notice it's mostly
just a major triad with underneath.
So if we were at a concert and we wanted to remember this,
we'd probably having a lot of skippy x's here.
We don't have time to get into the particulars of this,
but that's why we're doing of this diagramming stuff.
If you've got a lot of these skippy excess.
Um,
all right,
so let's listen to the first name of Mozart and a kind of knock musique
to this.
So maybe we've got a couple little ideas in here.
A,
B and c.
Ah,
agitation,
mood
knows the base
pause.
So we had a cadence there.
Dee Tee,
tee,
tee tee.
That will be the end of the musical phrase,
a cadence and the music actually stopped.
I should like to think of this in terms of it almost a drama.
We've got a change of scene here.
The,
there's some characters have gone off to stages now clear and other characters
are going to come on.
So what character is going to come on?
Well,
a more lyrical second theme.
I'm going to play just a bit of it for you.
What about this?
Is this a conjunct melody?
Obviously it's descending conjunct or discharge.
Very conjunct.
Actually it's just running down the scale now.
We don't have time because this music is going by so fast.
We've got her skippy opening theme going around like that.
We don't have time to sort of write down all those x's.
So maybe just,
yeah,
pop pop and maybe some feta or something like that.
So this is our first skippy theme.
Our second theme has a nice sort of fall to it.
Okay.
Here's the second thing.
Repeat.
Yeah.
Closing theme already.
Okay.
Hmm.
Let's just pause it here for a sec.
What's the most noteworthy aspect of that theme?
Pop,
pop,
pop.
What do you think?
Gotcha.
What would you remember about that?
How would you graph that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
let's start out with that.
It's really conjunct,
right?
Because nothing is just saying on one level,
sort of the ultimate conjunct,
uh,
join to the point that it's,
it's a unison pitch,
that tee,
tee,
tee tee.
So I'd remember that.
Just like this idea.
So our closing theme,
study that data,
turn it into almost the,
the woodpecker idea.
Sorry.
But think of that kind of data or maybe a machine got whatever's sort of sing a
silly analogy you want to construct to help you remember that.
Okay.
So here we are almost at the end of the exposition.
Let's listen now to the end of exposition and then we'll stop.
Okay.
So we're going to stop there.
Linda,
if now on this recording,
what do you think?
Uh,
well,
uh,
I think reasons for time.
Let's go ahead and we'll advance it up to the beginning of the development
section.
So now we should listen to this whole complex.
Once again,
we're not going to do that.
We're going to proceed here.
We're going to go into the development section and it's kind of fun the way
Mozart starts to develop development section here.
Hmm.
Let me ask you this.
We started here.
The development begins higher or lower.
Yeah.
Lower.
So he's dropped down to the dominant.
He's known the dominant.
And if he continued,
he as he had,
yeah,
that's what he would've done.
That's not what he does.
Okay.
He's sitting
ends up there.
So we get this sort of dissonance shift and it's a signal.
It's like the composure holding up a site development time for the development
now.
Okay.
So something we've shifted,
we were sort of slapping the face telling us we're at a new point in our form,
a new section in our form,
the development section.
So as we listened to this,
we'll hear Mozart move quickly through some,
uh,
lots of different keys.
I wouldn't be able to tell you what keys they are.
I really wouldn't.
Uh,
but I do know that he moves through different keys.
then we will hear a retransmission start.
But here's my challenge to you and why I started putting all these things up
here.
Which theme does he choose to develop here?
Kind of interesting.
Does he go with the first team?
Bomb,
bomb,
pop,
pop up.
So which one?
Okay,
stop it right there.
Oh,
here's all the way.
first of all,
what's the answer to the question?
Which theme did he use here?
We're now at the retransmission or almost finished the short development.
Which one did he use?
Who?
Who thinks they know?
Raise your hand.
Uh,
Elizabeth,
the closing Jews.
Just the closing thing.
But Dee Dee,
Dee Dee,
bup,
bup.
So nothing but the closing team in the short development section.
Now we are at the retransmission and you're going to hear the violins come down.
You,
I thought thought,
but if I could sing a harmony,
maybe we should all sing it together.
We'll be seeing
implied baseline.
Bob,
can I go bomb back to the tonic and when to go bomb.
Then that first theme is going to come back in here.
So let's listen to Mozart,
right?
A retransmission and I'm going to seeing the,
the implied or been sounded dominant.
That's going to lead to the tonic.
Ah,
all the first thing,
material coming back,
nothing
they knew.
Here it goes.
Our Bridge now movement
and he just cut it short is the first time he went to bump,
bump,
bump.
Bump is what the base yet this time he just stops the thing and stays in the
tonic key and then the rest of the material we'll come back in,
uh,
in the proper order in the tonic key.
All right,
we need not hear that.
Let's go on now to the Coda and we're just going to listen generally to what
happens in a Coda here.
Typical Coda with Mozart
tonic.
It's almost a stereotypical,
right?
Yeah.
You could have written that.
I could even,
I could have written that not so hard,
but as I say,
it's just a load of bricks to bring this thing to a conclusion.
But it's a beautiful example of Sonata Allegro form.
It doesn't what our model requires in all particulars in a PR,
in an unusually a rapid rate here,
about six minutes for this particular movement.
Let's go on to a rather,
another famous example of Sonata Lake Reform and that's the beginning of your
own Beethoven's Fifth Symphony symphony number five.
We of course worked with this before,
uh,
and you know the beginning,
but let's listen to a bit of this and we're going to follow it through now a all
the way to the,
into the exposition development in terms of form and not some of the issues
we're working with before.
But in terms of form,
no introduction
can just start you off with his first motive.
There are four note motive,
okay?
And now the bridge is going to start.
You get a sense of moving from point a to point B or from first theme,
two seconds.
Okay.
So I'll pause it there.
And the horn sort or
something like that,
you know,
this is the end of that.
And then a new uh,
lyrical theme.
Oh Man,
what interests always interested me here.
Sort of like the jaws movie.
You know,
you never know when it's safe to go back in the water.
Uh,
you've got this nice melody up dog,
but underneath you or did you do,
do sort of lurking under.
There is this
pernicious for note,
for note motive.
All right,
so let's listen to the second theme as it starts in the violins and then we'll
build up with Beethoven here,
building up dynamics and kitsch.
Little bit of interest to see here our closing theme
and let's stop it right there.
A couple of points.
No,
to get,
sort of breathe the air of this particular performance.
Ah,
okay.
It's because we're going to change to a different recording now.
Um,
so Linda,
you go ahead and change to that and while you're changing,
let me comment on the closing theme.
Notice how in the symphony,
Beethoven once again is obsessed with this four note motive.
We heard it underneath
and at the end,
how does he create a closing thing?
Well,
just coming down and our page,
you'll just taking that,
that triad,
is this a major triad or minor triad?
What is it in relationship to the opening tonality?
It's the relative major.
Okay.
So he's got to come up to
sure.
Everything's sort of short,
short law.
All right.
So that's how he constructs the closing theme.
Just a different configuration of that short,
short,
long motive.
Let's go back now and here a a different recording.
And tell me what you think about this recording.
Uh,
how's it differ from the preceding one that we were listening to
at the,
uh,
it's your left.
Let's start with,
uh,
the,
second,
uh,
repeat of the beginning.
If you can get their repeat of the exposition.
Perfect.
Okay.
Any thoughts about that?
Just a one playing.
I know it's hard.
I should sit the two up here and play this one four times in this room.
Four Times back and forth.
What about this one though?
Yeah.
Second one.
Sounds faster.
Yeah,
it's a company.
I mean it's the same music.
They had the same score.
One conductor thinks it should go yell at the T.
Dot.
T t.
T.
That's how Leonard Bernstein would do it.
And did do it.
Um,
another conductor still living conducting a frequently in New York also Bernard
high tank.
Yeah.
T t t t t t team [inaudible].
If it gets through,
there's about 30,
this exposition about 30 seconds faster than Leonard Bernstein did.
Just a difference in interpretation.
So let's listen now quickly,
uh,
because it does go quickly to Bernard high tanks,
interpretation of the exposition of this first movement.
Hmm.
Okay.
That's probably enough of that.
Let's go on to the development now.
Development.
Well,
how's the development of this symphony stars?
Which team is he using?
Well,
you can imagine,
oops,
I've got to get the right pages up here.
It's four no motive.
Same thing.
Mozart did it lot a time lock music throws in a highly dissonant chord to
announce that beginning of the development section.
Then rather quickly,
he modulates through different keys.
Every time you hear the string sweep,
moving to a new key and then
modulating to a higher key there,
then he begins to build up upside lost.
My piece of paper here begins to build up in terms of
taking it up higher and higher and higher.
And then we get,
Oh,
uh huh.
That's sort of say,
okay,
well first of all,
um,
let's talk about this core.
What do you think about that in court?
Oh,
a full attention dissonance.
Yeah.
Um,
it's called a diminished triad.
And we've put this up here,
member,
we've had major triads with a major third and a bottom minor third on the top.
And then we had minor triads.
But what would happen if you constructed a triad with just a minor third on the
bottom and then another minor third,
two minor thirds?
Will you get this sort of more dissonant Sam?
More biting sound.
So that's what Beethoven is using here.
Um,
this dissonance.
Try it.
There's another thing that's quite interesting and that is that this idea of
just pounding away on one particular,
particular core.
This sounds,
uh,
that sort of thing.
Beethoven started doing this.
You ever have your CD player gets,
yeah.
MMM.
You crazy.
Right?
Uh,
why is he doing this?
And thank you.
Think about how the audience of that time would have perceived this.
You know,
the,
what did the Germans have of 1808 sink lymphic lymphic hostels are here.
This isn't,
my nickname was sick since he fuck click,
here's the music.
So this is a,
this kind of thing.
[inaudible]
it's almost like the kinds of things he used to use,
you know,
sign old silent movies and then they tied her up,
lit the fuse,
building a pension.
If you take this diminished triad to keep placing it,
it's successively higher degrees of scale,
the scale,
you'll get this extreme of tension.
And what she'd done in terms of of note values here,
well we have this
[inaudible]
it's almost as if he stripped it down to just one note,
sort of reduced it to its most elemental.
And I says,
well,
I could give you metaphors about taking matter and reduced them down to some
sort of their dentist potential and atomic explosions.
And things like that.
Yeah.
It's kind of what he's done here.
He's,
it hasn't expanded in the development section.
He's contractive.
He's contracted sort of to maximize the rhythmic energy,
almost electrical energy,
uh,
inherit in this particular particular concept.
Well,
all right.
So then he backs off of this
and then he starts playing around with just two now,
why two notes?
Well,
there's original,
just two notes in it and then he breaks it down to just one note.
Once again,
a reaching for the essence here.
Now this might not sound like OneNote,
but here's what he said.
Gotcha.
That sounds like high,
low,
high,
low.
But if you stop and think about it,
they're just coming an octave.
So he's really just working within one note.
Then he changes it
and then the theme,
not me,
but the diminished chord won't let it in and just sort of keeps repeating that
one note idea,
hi Lo
high,
low,
my way,
this sort of insistent moda
down the door.
And then the recapitulation can begin.
And so the recapitulation begins at that point.
So that's the development section of the,
um,
uh,
of the Fifth Symphony here,
first movement,
and the fifth symphony where it puts this electrical moment right in the smack,
in the middle of the development section in the middle of the movement.
And then we get to the recapitulation.
So we've heard,
uh,
some music of Leonard Bernstein's interpretation of this.
We've heard Bernard high tinks interpretation of this.
Now let's go on to,
as you go out,
you can use this as kind of exit music,
silly,
a bit of silliness here.
The BGS interpretation of Beethoven's Fifth Symphony.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].